[Music]
good morning everybody it's seven
o'clock you're waking up this morning to
a new set of coved rules including the
need for passports to access some venues
but is it enough to stop the spread of
omicron and despite assurances from the
government to us that no further
restrictions are imminent if not enough
people are getting boosted is our new
year under threat
and will many of us be spending
christmas alone in isolation the
transport secretary grant chaps on the
programme very shortly we're also asking
how the variant will affect travel next
year with the boss of heathrow airport
plus
a quarantini or a snack sittant we'll
find out what kind of day it is with the
linguist susie dent as she sets a phrase
or word for every single day of the year
and
cool runnings we'll talk to the
fundraiser nearing the end of his chilly
epic quest to walk around the uk and
ireland
in his speedos it's wednesday the 15th
of december
new rules covet passes for some venues
to stop the spread of omicron and fears
further restrictions could be needed
despite the government telling us
yesterday no plans are in the pipeline
and as cues continue for those keen to
get their booster jab is the government
on track to hit its target
here in south africa early signs suggest
omicron may be less deadly than
previously feared with doctors urging
the uk not to overreact
please don't don't just don't say these
type of things
don't
because that is hysteria
goodness bon voyage red list as the
government says it will try to release
many travelers from their hotel
quarantine
nibbling at the rules the former
conservative who's quit as chair of the
london assembly's police and crime
committee after being accused of
breaking coveted rules at that party
caused her resignations as a mum and her
partner prepare to be sentenced today
over the death of the toddler star
hobson
[Music]
singing
as a band backs the jailed british woman
will speak to her husband about his
hopes for her release from captivity in
iran
surely heartland but
for how much longer we investigate if
the voters of north shropshire still
back boris as they prepare to vote in a
crucial by-election
[Music]
[Applause]
a soundtrack of african history the
congolese rumba is added to unesco's
world heritage list
[Music]
so many questions we need answering
today on behalf of the government we
have got grant chaps very shortly before
that big breaking news from the city
helen and standing by for us helen am
good morning uh there you are good
morning tell me
good morning kay so we've got the
monthly inflation figures this morning
for the month
of november at the the cpi we call it
the consumer price index is essentially
the standard cost of a basket of goods
and services it tells us how much things
are costing and it's gone up really
significantly uh in the year to the
month of november 5.1
uh just to put that in some context
that's uh significantly higher than what
economists thought it would be it was
predicted to be about 4.7
the bank of england's target for
inflation is about 2
so looking inflation of 5.1 percent uh
is certainly uh significant uh there's a
few key drivers to what might be pushing
this the fuel price is a big one in
particular there are some particular
things that happened in november as well
for example at the introduction of
extra costs on the on tobacco that was
introduced in the government in the
budget excuse me so that will have made
a difference too but really uh last
month in the month of october when we
saw a jump of inflation of 4.2 we all
said that was very big and there were
some very specific obvious things that
caused that including a rise in the
off-gen price cap so the fact this has
gone up so much in november without
those very specific drivers is extremely
uh significant there was lots of talk
and worries about us hitting this uh
this this number in at the beginning of
next year it coming so soon will be a
big concern for the chancellor and the
uh bank of england who'll be setting
interest rates tomorrow okay helen and
thank you very much indeed talking about
that throughout the course of the
program before that though let's speak
to this uh transport secretary grant
shaps here on behalf of the government
this morning good morning thank you for
finding us
it's good to have you in the studio
let's deal with the data to start with
um as far as the omicron variant is
concerned how many people in hospital
this morning with omicron the last week
last figure we had is unchanged the 10
people in hospital we know there's been
a single death
and we know there's probably around 9
000 people who have tested positive at
this stage how many on ventilators uh
none on ventilators that i'm aware of
although i don't specifically know the
condition of the 10 in hospital so there
may be some of those the person that
died did they die
having gone into hospital with omicron
or did they again i don't know the
specific details of that uh individuals
so does that suggest we've got this
under control
no i mean what we do know is that it's
doubling every two to three days which
is incredibly fast and the thing about
doubling rates like that is you can go
from seemingly almost nothing of course
to suddenly uh it becoming a thing which
overwhelms you and i think that the
hospitalizations are in many senses a
lagging part of this because we know
from
coronavirus as a whole it takes a while
two or three weeks before people find
themselves in hospital and sadly another
two or three weeks before people
die although of course we hope it might
be
more
you know less
less severe we just don't know whether
it is at this stage well dr angelique
cutsia
as you know south african scientists
saying the uk is being alarmist
in its response well i'm surprised to
hear that and actually i know there are
different voices in south africa and
i've listened to a lot of them if you
look at south african hospitalizations
you see that very very quick as i say
the doubling rate becomes an issue and i
was having a look at the data on this
just yesterday morning
and you can see the speed at which
people are going into hospital now there
are all sorts of arguments about how
severe it is how long you spend in
hospital the big problem that we want to
try and avoid is having our hospitals so
full up that when it comes to you
needing to call uh you know for for an
ambulance accidents emergency elective
surgery that you can't get into hospital
to do any of those things and it's our
responsibility obviously as a government
as a country to make sure that that
doesn't happen yeah although there are
only nine in hospital aren't there sadly
one person but it's this whole thing is
only a couple weeks old at this point
it's not though we've known about it
since october well in terms of the
number of people having it here we know
that you know the first case was in
october of course but if i look in the
last three months ago sure but if i look
in the last two days for example uh i
can see there's three or four thousand
new cases
right at the beginning of this and let's
call that the beginning of december um
when we when we first started to pick
them up um here uh the cases were
increasing at just two or three a day so
you see what happens the doubling rate
means that if you don't act you'd be the
first person on your program to say why
didn't you act sooner
do you recognize the figure of 200 000 a
day contracting covered 200 000 a day is
based on the fact that people get tested
and when they're tested they're included
in the official cases but the office of
national statistics and others have
always made estimates of what the likely
total
amount of coronavirus is and that
includes people who haven't necessarily
received a positive test as yet a
cambridge statistician professor spiegel
halter says that's just naughty without
context oh well again i think it does
need to be used in context and and very
clear about it there's a difference if
you take a test and that test is
positive then that gets included in the
data but there are other organizations
including the office for national
statistics as coincidentally my family
has been on the office of national
statistics monthly survey right since
the beginning of
coronavirus was randomly
uh selected i suppose uh and they do
those wider surveys now they they they
do those tests monthly on the whole
population to take a sample size uh so
people are so you've got a regular
baseline for these things okay and
that's how these you know estimates of
what it might mean in the wider
population
abroad come about through those um
significant sample sizes more figures um
reported in the newspapers this morning
more than a million people could be in
isolation by christmas day is that a
figure that you recognize well look i i
hope it's the case that all these steps
we're taking
most significant of all getting people
boosted means that we don't end up in
that kind of situation um the the
frightening thing is if you do nothing
if it doesn't turn out to be less severe
than we think oh we hope uh if uh if if
we just left it to chance as i've
already said you you'd be having me and
you don't recognize those figures say
well we hope to avoid anything like that
of course yeah in the in the meantime um
the last three days i've gone on to the
nhs website to look for the lateral flow
tests that they're not there
that's a supply issue
um should we be prioritizing care home
residents and nhs workers so that um nhs
workers can go to work and care home
residents can have visitors first of all
just on the tests themselves these
lateral flow tests which actually
uniquely and as far as i can see the
there aren't other countries who've been
supplying these free of charge to their
citizens and major economies don't
haven't generally been doing this and we
have in this country you're right that
particularly since the
new measures the booster program asking
people to be tested come in um it can be
difficult at different times a day to
get those i did notice yesterday
actually that at certain time today you
could get them they're coming back in
there's plenty of supply in the country
what we're having issues with is the
distribution route and i know my
colleagues at the health department are
working with royal mail with amazon with
others to try and make sure that
distribution gets out and you can still
go to pharmacies well they also say
potentially not should you uh be
prioritizing care home residents
absolutely i think you know care homes
hospitals very very important and most
important of all if there's one single
message from all of this
boosters 24 million people boosted
already i saw huge queues just i walked
past huge queues yesterday of people
responding to what the prime minister
said on sunday night and going in
booking and and waiting for many
walk-ins can't say the brits are not
doing their bit they
are queuing up for hours and hours um
the scots are saying the public uh
should be limiting socializing to three
households at a time in the run-up to
christmas good idea
well look every part of the uk will have
a look at this and then they make their
own um plans the scots i think have
issued as guidance rather than law in
their particular case we set out in
england for people watching this in
england uh what we uh want to do
parliament's now uh voted on it um and
uh right now that does not include
limitations we want people to be able to
enjoy christmas this year we're
certainly in a better position than we
were this time last year so the scots
can do that but the br the english are
not doing it yeah it's only in guidance
yeah in scotland so that's but that's
right we we want people to be sensible
but to enjoy their christmas to get
tested and we have two things this year
which we didn't last year one's tests
and two
jabs and and now even booster jabs
that's all happened in the last year so
we're in a much better position
okay everybody i talked to minister um
says to me when you get that minister on
your show can you get them to guarantee
there will not be any further
restrictions ahead of christmas well
look i i dominic rob yesterday said
there won't be as long as it's this
variant well well look i i i know that
we've taken a huge number of steps we've
already got over 40 people boosted uh
people watching this can help by making
sure they book their booster jab if it's
been three months since their second one
and that way we can all enjoy christmas
and so i think with um some confidence
we can say that people are going to be
able to enjoy their christmas get
together with their friends and families
and no more restrictions
and with only what has already been okay
will everybody be jabs by new year's eve
um everyone would have been offered a
jab who wants one are you sure oh that's
the plan uh it depends somewhat on your
on your viewers of course people have to
actually come forward we can't make
people and do that everyone wants to
once we've had one but
offered a jab i imagine that some people
for various different reasons uh may uh
get their jobs in the new year where for
example they're having to wait because
it's more than three months for whatever
reason they less than three months and
they didn't have their second job until
whenever so
obviously some people will still be
coming through the system the key thing
is everyone to be offered a jab and as
we're seeing you know again there's no
other country i'm aware of certainly no
other major economy where over 40 of
their citizens have already had the
booster jab we got the original vaccine
program done first and we're getting
this booster program done first and that
will give us better protection including
against omicron and when will the third
job been absolutely essential to get
into places um that that we agreed to
that parliament agreed to yesterday so
it will not be gatherings in the last
not this year um
i'm told
i think we'll have to see what the
evidence shows us nearer the time i
think i mean i think your question's
hinting at will there be a time at which
three jabs is then saying that you're
fully vaccinated
it wasn't very soft
you're right no you're right you're
right
and and look i i speak to my opposite
numbers in other countries transport
secretaries from around the world
particularly from the g7 this year that
which we're
we're hosting and uh they're saying look
we're going to switch to requiring
people to have that third jab before
they're able to come into their
countries so i think and eventually it
becomes inevitable because other
countries will require it for us you
just don't know when yes and i i don't
know what that time will be not this
year as i say but right now potentially
yourself
okay
let's talk about this um tory rebellion
dominick rahm told me yesterday deputy
prime minister sat just there he said
he'd be surprised if the number was as
high as 70. it was almost a hundred
you've lost the dressing room well look
i'd say nobody wants to curtail people's
freedoms and mps rightly take that very
very seriously and have to think about
how they
how they how they vote in the end
parliament uh passed these measures with
the majority of nearly 250 but each
individual mp has had to think it
through very carefully
and i i completely understand that we
don't want to have to put these steps in
place on the other hand as i said a
couple of times we don't want to
afterwards end up having to look back
and wish we had it's not answering my
question
how so and you've lost the dressing room
even apology even an mp that is the
newest mp that happens to be a
conservative um mp and even he voted
against the prime minister well as i say
losing the dressing room would be
parliament not supporting you parliament
has supported these measures um and i
but i you had to rely on labour though
well if labour hadn't voted they still
would have gone through of course but uh
you know based on on the numbers but
that's not the point and i do appreciate
that every mp has to think very
carefully and and look particularly as a
conservative i hate the idea of
curtailing people's freedom to act and
to do different things as it so happens
we've actually managed because of our
vaccine program and booster program to
be one of the most open of certainly
european countries in most other places
including for example
in france you have to show vaccine
certification just to get on a train
long distance
but we've not had to bring those things
in here yeah because of the booster
program and i think it's really
important that we keep reminding all of
our you know all of us that the way to
prevent having to do these things is to
make sure we all get our jabs and
boosters what if you lose the
by-election will you have lost the
dressing room then well look
governing's you know difficult uh and
you you don't have uh you know there's
especially with something like corona
virus there's no text but there's no
manual to work through and i think you
know this government would have done
some things where we haven't got it
right and we can back through
coronavirus we've also done some things
where we've absolutely got it spot on
what have you done and as say things
like the vaccine program has been one of
those
in mid parliament all sorts of different
things happen so you will wait shaping
up to potentially accept that you might
lose
having these conversations so it was
absolutely absolutely not going to
happen the bookies have said you've got
no chances the lib dems well i i one
thing i've known from for being in
politics for for a while and haven't
been party chairman is never to become
the pundit on your on your sofa you've
got plenty of guests who'll do that why
don't we leave it to the voters but
you're preparing for potentially losing
i said i don't want to preempt what
voters decide to do that's their
business and uh i'm sure afterwards you
can analyze the results or i'm sure
there are plenty of people to do that
for you what i do know is that people in
north shropshire have the opportunity
and i met the candidate um to vote for
for for a potential mp who worked very
very hard for the for their area and i
know about all of his transport
priorities because i've been up to see
them okay let me ask you another couple
questions before i let you go these
downing street parties um they just
won't go away will they sean bailey's
reside from his role as chair of the
london assembly police and crime
committee um after that picture
did he do the right thing
well absolutely right thing to resign
but the wrong thing to have held a party
i mean point out this is not a uh this
this is something that was organized by
uh that i guess islam doesn't matter
who's a campaign team yeah i see in that
picture apparently four
uh conservative party workers who are on
secondment where disciplinary action has
already been taken um and you know to
answer your question it's disgraceful to
have a party like that break the rules
that's unacceptable and the consequences
that follow following so if he stepped
down what about the prime minister he
was ringmaster over a quiz with names
like professor quiz witty hands face
first place
next slide please and the participants
were told to go out by the back door
once it was over well come on i i saw
the i mean the photo you just showed um
shows a lot of people not socially
distanced absolutely unacceptable
disgraceful i saw the photo of the prime
minister so so-called uh quiz
saturn
that was him but who was he on the zoo
and he was reading out the names of the
quiz of the teams the guns faced first
place come on prime minister hold on a
minute he sat in front of a computer
thanking his staff for 10 or 15 minutes
for having worked through christmas on a
virtual you didn't write he did a quiz
ride i don't think there's really an
issue as far as i'm aware there's no
issue that i'm that i'm familiar with
where you can't have quiz names over the
video screen at christmas i think that's
all getting a little bit silly the other
picture you just showed well that is
obviously okay there's lots more to ask
about that but i do we're over so i just
want to ask you briefly before i let you
go as a parent
how can you um reconcile the abuse that
children
are facing as a result some would say
of lockdown there's two babies the
images that we've seen i i don't i can't
even i i actually um you know i said to
my to my wife i mean as as as a dad i
said to my wife i actually can't read
the detail i had to force myself on that
first picture it's heartbreaking
actually heartbreaking to see it and um
you know lock down i know lockdown
obviously there's no excuse i know that
my colleague nadeem zahawi the education
secretary's um looking into this and
announcing inquiries are not enough
though i know there is nothing that will
bring that back and it is you know
difficult to see it in any other way as
just just pure evil yeah and this was
the little boy last week as well
heartbreaking absolutely heartbreaking
every parent in the country will be
reading this and seeing the story this
morning and feeling the same way
i must let you go um it's great to have
you in the studio finally uh come back
soon thank you very much thanks a lot
um
hammer blow to the prime minister's
authority that's what the telegraph is
saying this morning as a result
of the
the vote last night several votes the
guardian also leads with the pm's
humiliating
rebellion the times reports the result
was far bigger than what number 10 and
the whips had expected
the ft says tonight's events are the
biggest setback of boris johnson's
premiership
the metro calls it the pm's christmas
stuffing
and the latest allegation about a
rule-breaking party in westminster
during the lockdown last december makes
the front page of the mirror the paper
prints a photograph which appears to
show a group of conservative staff
enjoying plenty of food alongside the
parties candidate for london mayor that
was sean bailey he stepped down we're
hearing there from the minister that
several uh conservative workers that
were on secondment are now being
investigated in that picture
and as we've been saying new rules
coming into force in england this
morning to try to stop the spread of
omicron including the need for covert
passports to access some venues
businesses are warning that they are on
the brink of collapse already and need
help as katie spencer reports
at the cause in tottenham they aren't
exactly dancing with delight at how
covered passports will impact business
it's completely messed the market up
yeah people
people's confidence has gone maybe not
getting the bar revenue for that which
is it just majorly messes up your
business model i think we are unfairly
targeted to be honest
it isn't the only business now legally
required to carry out covid's status
checks the rules affect any nightclub or
indoor unseated venue with a classity of
more than 500 people unseated outdoor
venues that hold more than four thousand
and any venue with more than ten 000
people
which makes the very british tradition
of football at christmas a bit more
complicated this year
it is inconvenient for some people and i
have to tell fans you know prepare and
know what you need to do in order to get
into the stadium of course if you're not
vaccinated you can also do a lateral
flow test
but it will probably take a little bit
longer to get into the stadium
it is a complicated and contradictory
set of lines drawn up by the government
work from home but you can have a
christmas party now if that party's in
the pub and there's music and dancing
that's fine but if you end up going to a
nightclub after that then you all have
to prove that you've been double jabbed
go to the cinema or the theater and
because you're seated it's fine just to
wear a mask i think it is kind of
unfavorable it takes away people's
freedom it takes away people's
human rights essentially i think it's
your responsibility to kind of read up
and make sure that you're up to date
with the latest rules and know what you
need to do to kind of help everyone else
out each to their own i'm definitely
pro-choice but i'm also pro-common sense
i absolutely agree with the rules but i
just don't think
they're
sufficient enough to
protect it they fear it'll only
discourage people from going out katie
spencer sky news
still to come on the programme for you
as the red list ends will people start
flying will be joined by the boss of
heath rowe very shortly
the husband of nazan and zagari ratcliff
will tell us why he's increasingly
hopeful she could soon be released from
captivity in iran
and we'll hear how you can travel from
portugal to singapore
by train
when railway writer mark smith joins us
also making the news this morning for
you president biden is expected to meet
survivors and relatives of those who
died in the kentucky tornado today 74
people have perished in the incident on
friday night
hundreds of homes have been destroyed
while thousands more remain without
power
26 of the 27 people who died last month
after a boat capsized in the english
channel as they tried to reach the uk
have been formally identified french
authorities say the migrants included
seven women a teenager and a
seven-year-old girl
now it's the dance of love and romance
from africa and now it's been given
protected stasis
[Music]
unesco has awarded special status to the
economy's
congolese rumba after lobbying by
diplomats from the democratic republic
of congo and congo brazzerville the drc
culture minister told the u.n that the
dance has been part of our identity
throughout the ages that's your ear worm
for this morning ladies and gentlemen
now the nhs is stepping up efforts to
deliver a record number of booster shots
and stop the spread of omicron
emma birchley is at a vaccine center in
west london for us hi emma good morning
i'm guessing they're expecting another
raft of people coming today
yes the first people arrived here at 6
15 this morning and i had a little chat
with them and actually half of the
people who had come here this morning
already
were in that younger age group so the
under 30s they only became eligible to
have their jab from today but they
decided to come along and queue up they
don't actually start doing the uh
injections until half a state but
they've let them in
to wait inside but we've seen enormous
cues up and down the country and
actually in parts of london
yesterday people were waiting seven
hours to have their booster jab
and it's caused the whole booking system
to really creak under the strain which
is why a lot of people have wanted to
come along
and queue up
so that they can get their job because
the government says that they want every
single adult who's eligible to be
offered a jab by the end of this year so
that's bringing that target forward by a
month now professor chris whittie the
chief medical officer says this is
needed because there is a significant
risk of an increase in hospitalizations
because of just how infectious this
omicron variant is now the official
figures yesterday were 5
346 figures but that's believed to be a
significant underestimation of it the
health security agency estimates that
actually there are 200 000
infections a day and that that could go
up significantly so that is why people
are being urged to come along and get
their booster when they can
thanks so much indeed thanks a lot
although we've been hearing of course
haven't we from um a cambridge um
scientist this morning saying the
government's a bit naughty with those
200 000 figures and they need to be
taken
in context as far as the number of
people in hospital are concerned that
number remaining at nine or ten and one
person sadly having died on record as a
result of the omicron variant
a leading south african doctor says the
uk is panicking unnecessarily over
omicron dr angeli angelique kutzia who
first alerted the world to the new covid
variant says its effects there appear to
be much milder than delta well let's uh
catch up with john again should we in
johannesburg he's been chatting to us
all week hello to you again um john so
the scientists in south africa are
saying don't panic britain
yeah i think that i was just talking
with one of my colleagues actually we
feel like we're living in a in a
different universe to a certain extent i
mean there are a couple of issues here
huge number of infections nobody doubts
that
omicron is spreading through this
country like wildfire
but that hasn't been matched by high
numbers of hospitalizations that that
just hasn't happened at least yet
hospitals here in halting in central uh
south africa they're still accepting
patients with other conditions with
other illnesses and i think there's
another issue as well south africa has
some of the world's best doctors some of
the world's best
scientists and i think there is a
feeling amongst some of them that that
their views their real world experience
here is being overlooked and when they
hear talk in the uk of one million
infections by the end of the month by
the nhs being overwhelmed by omicron
cases well at the moment i think some of
them feel that that sounds a bit
alarmist have a have a listen to the
chair of the south african medical
association
the prime minister
definitely please don't don't just don't
say these type of things
don't
because that is hysteria
it's early days here in south africa but
there has been encouraging news on
vaccines for example and i think people
people here just aren't prepared to
panic yet
just a quick thought before i let you go
john very quick um they must be relieved
that um south africa coming off the red
list
absolutely uh relieved um
people were really angry about that here
and it's done real damage to the economy
i think people are still a bit angry
because they're not going to get these
tourists back they really depend on on
tourists particularly british tourists
to stimulate the economy but i think
glad that it's over a bit of a nightmare
for south africa
okay thanks a lot john thank you i did
look um at a flight to africa as soon as
they came off the red list within an
hour
it had gone up more than
125 percent
quick look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
the rest of the week will be fairly
settled with temperatures returning to
near average but there'll be some rain
around it's mostly mild and grey start
with rain in the north but central parts
are rather chilly with some fog patches
northern areas of both the uk and
ireland will stay murky through the
morning with further spells of rain but
northern scotland will turn drier and
brighter
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
this is what the weather was looking
like
yesterday stunning early morning
pictures uh from liverpool there you go
the liver building
just poking up
from the mist there how cool
is that it says the birds perched on the
royal liver building presiding over a
sea of white as morning mists rolled
through liverpool yesterday
uh incredible pictures of the famous
liver building featuring as you saw
there in today's times i loved this
taking it to absolutely even teddy bears
need to protect themselves with a mask
um every now and again millions of us
the journey home for christmas has begun
two years after the last proper
get-together that's a picture in the
guardian of kayla a student in new york
because she wants uh she waits rather
for her train
the teddy bear what's his name well of
course we've done our research he's
called james
and the incredible hard work of workers
at a brick factory in bangladesh
featuring in the telegraph it shows this
lady who moves finnish bricks around the
site on a head each one weighs more than
two
kilos that
is what you call heavy lifting
now the government has told us this
morning it could become
mandatory to have a booster shot that
we're not sure of at this stage it's
likely that that's going to be the case
but we don't know when we also believe
that there aren't going to be any more
restrictions
this side
of christmas we also believe well here
this is what he said
i i speak to my opposite numbers in
other countries transport secretaries
from around the world particularly from
the g7 this year that which we're we're
hosting and uh they're saying look we're
going to switch to requiring people to
have that third jab before they're able
to come into their countries so i think
and eventually it becomes inevitable
because other countries will require it
for us you just don't know when yes and
i i don't know what that time will be
not this year as i say but right now
potentially
kate is with us um the rebels are not
going to like that either are they kate
well i think it's inevitable and i think
that's part of the question that many of
them had around covert certification
because there was this worry that okay
well this is what you're saying right
now but what are you going to be saying
to me in two months time three months
time and that's the unpredictability of
a global pandemic it's a problem for the
government because they don't have the
full data without it's very hard to try
and get people behind your policy but i
thought that it was really interesting
in your discussion with grant chaps when
you were asking him about lateral flow
tests about trying to make sure that
people can be at home for christmas to
see their families that figure of a
million people potentially isolating he
said he wanted to avoid it with those
jabs but you asked about lateral flow
tests and he said yes the nhs and care
homes should be prioritized for those
tests if they are hard to get now i've
been on this morning you can get them
they are available online but there is
still some difficulty when it comes to
getting them in pharmacies and that's
worrying people so if the government is
now going to prioritize care homes that
would be great news for anyone wanting
to visit a relative who was worried
about that i think that would be really
positive news what's more difficult
though for grant chaps was around
restrictions and around the questions
about where this goes next because as
we've said before without the data it's
really hard to say lucky you for being
able to get them i went on and i there
were no tests available oh really yeah
so i think you just have to keep trying
i think yeah that's the message from us
this morning isn't it okay keep trying
yeah we'll see you in the next hour
thanks very much meantime big change
this morning in the covid travel
restrictions in the early hours
quarantine for travellers was abandoned
as the red list was scrapped joined now
by the chief exec officer of heathrow
and that's john holland okay hello to
you is this a happy day
it is it's good news that we're getting
rid of the red list and if you remember
the government said that when a micron
was first identified we needed some
measures to slow down the introduction
just until a micron became endemic in
the uk the red list for
certain countries
pcr testing within two days for everyone
arriving in the uk and then
pre-departure testing before they got on
a plane now they're taking away the red
list because it is now endemic we want
to see the other test taken away as well
because that way we can start to get
back to normal and give people a more
predictable journey into the uk
what do travellers need to know
if they're heading away over christmas
well first of all we're going to be
keeping them safe while they're
traveling through the airport so we have
all of the covid protections that we
have here the second thing they need to
look at is what the measures are that
the country they're going to will
require them to take and some of them
still require a level of testing or
forms to be filled out so make sure you
fill those out before you get to the
airport if you can and that'll make it a
quicker journey traveling through and
give you more security when you get to
your destination we do have pcr testing
and other forms of testing here at
heathrow we're keeping the cost down as
much as we can so do pre-book if you can
so that we can make your journey as
smooth and quick as possible
are you able to cope with the demand
because i know uh when these latest day
two tests and also
um yeah the day day naught to two tests
uh came in again at the end of last
month it's putting a huge demand on the
testing ability at airports
it has been particularly when these
measures come in overnight we need to
scale up the supply very quickly that's
exactly what we have been doing making
it easy for people to take the test
before they even come to the airport and
that allows people to have a much more
predictable journey and take some of the
stress out of the journey but the best
thing the government can do now is to
remove the requirements for all this
testing if they've taken away the red
list then they're accepting that the
micron strain is now endemic in the uk
so why not take away the other testing
that they only introduced as a temporary
measure there's no need to extend that
beyond today
now that the red list has gone why are
we waiting until january before that
will be reviewed many people are worried
about their own christmases and whether
they'll be able to get away on their
journeys visiting loved ones just
because of the uncertainty that is
introduced the government can solve that
uncertainty and let ritz get their
christmas back
we heard a confirmation from the
government for the first time today in
the form of grant chaps that soon you're
going to have to have three vaccine
doses in order to be able to go about
some parts of everyday life do you know
when you're going to need those to have
to fly
no we don't and if you remember up until
a few weeks ago if you had been doubly
vaccinated you didn't need to take any
tests when you came back into the uk and
that's because we relied on the covid
variant so
on the covet vaccination now i assume
that what is meaning is that in future
you'll need three jabs rather than two
jabs to be able to travel without any
form of testing now for those people who
don't have the three jabs i imagine that
they will still need to
do some testing when they come into the
uk but the vast majority of travelers
will have been fully vaccinated and will
be able to travel as normal and that's
what we need to get back to we can't
close down the economy every time there
is a variant for concern we need to take
a lead in the uk by opening up travel
again as soon as it is safe to do so and
get back to the frictionless travel that
we all enjoyed a couple of years ago so
there shouldn't be any tests and there
shouldn't be any requirements for these
long lists that the government is
currently asking for that's the goal we
should get back to but until we have got
through a micron and got a playbook for
how to deal with variance concern i'm
afraid that uh travel is going to be
just a little bit harder and fewer
people will be traveling than were
traveling before a micron came along
and you take me to uh my final question
if i may please mr holland
last time this happened africa and the
african countries were just off the red
list for a matter of six weeks i think
and then they were straight back on
again there must be at that niggling
thought in the back of your head how
long for this time
yes of course and and we're going to be
living with them with uh kovid for the
foreseeable future so and we can't lock
down every time this happens by all
means let's have
some uh measures temporarily as we have
had in place for the last couple of
weeks but let's lift them as soon as we
can either because the new variant is
endemic or because we found it is less
of a concern than they used to be and
there needs to be some that they need to
come in quickly and go away just as
quickly so we can start to get people
back to normal a lot of people are put
offline because of the risk that new
tests will and measures will come in
overnight and they'll find themselves
having gone through a quick business
trip and suddenly they find themselves
stuck in another country and until we
get rid of that uncertainty for
passengers a lot of people will be put
off travelling and that is holding back
the economy it's not just for business
people but also for tourists coming into
the uk students coming into the uk this
is part of what supports millions of
jobs right across the country and the
government needs to take a lead in
removing all of these unnecessary tests
as fast as possible and getting business
back to normal
okay i'm intrigued to know why you say
oh micron every time i talk to somebody
they pronounce it differently
well i studied classics so this is this
is oh okay i'm going with that then yep
it's a micron
o micron an omega so o micron is a
little o and omega is a big
it's good to talk to you thank you very
much indeed thanks a lot okay
thank you thankfully it's pie next now
after a major rebellion by his own mps
over covered rules boris johnson is just
days away from another potential
political problem on thursday voters in
the conservative seat of north
shropshire tomorrow go to the polls in a
by-election triggered by the resignation
of owen patterson following his failed
attempt to avoid suspension for breaking
parliamentary rules there's plenty at
stake for all the major parties as our
people and politics correspondent nick
martin reports
the christmas trees are selling well at
petra cloud farm
no one here wants to be dragged back
into tougher coved restrictions
the new variant it could be affecting
business people coming out especially
the vulnerable and the older generation
there is a by-election here tomorrow to
elect a new mp
north shropshire is a rock-solid tory
seat
but could accusations of sleaze in
westminster turn loyal conservatives
like mayrig into floating voters it's
difficult for them whoever's in power
you know boris johnson you know
he's had a difficult time you know in
parliament and things and so decisions
at westminster parties at downing street
perceptions of whether the government
are making the right decisions is not
enough to make you change your habits of
a lifetime no not not not yet as i say
you know next few weeks
could be different i'm a bit of a
floating voter i can't lie i don't know
my vote's just up for grabs by anyone at
the minute this is catherine louis and
rhys they're studying at the local
college and i want to know if
allegations of parties and rule breaking
has shaped the way they intend to vote
i'm mortified the government would even
do that
they've posed restrictions on us we've
abided by it
and now they're laughing in our face
and someone who spent six months in his
house in lockdown trying to save his
parents
from not getting coveted
i just it's gonna change my vote and i'm
gonna vote for labour
i've never really gone deeply into
politics but i definitely think after
the last year i will be looking more
deeply
i don't think the government
or politicians are as competent as i
used to think they were especially over
the past few weeks with what's happened
what's been in the news and some of the
leaked things that have happened i think
i've personally lost complete confidence
in the government and all that has a
that that has changed that has changed
the way you will vote i'm gonna switch
i'm not voting conservative this
election i won't be voting conservative
in the next general election or the
election after that
amanda roberts owns a cafe in nearby
oswestry it's just getting back on its
feet since lockdown ended she'll vote
tomorrow she just doesn't know who four
yet up until the last minute i really
won't know what to think that's caused
by
events of the last few weeks and months
yes really yes because you know all
different things have happened and it's
like oh
this isn't good or you know and that's
shaking your face yes he says yeah
that makes this by-election very
interesting a defeat here would spell
trouble for the tories nick martin sky
news north shropshire
nice and breaking news um just reaching
us here on the breakfast program at sky
sketchy but important enough to bring to
you at this early stage we are being
told that
360 people are trapped on the roof of
the world trade center building in hong
kong
they are currently awaiting rescue that
according uh to police who's saying that
350 to 360 people
are trapped on the roof of the world
trade center building in hong kong
apparently there has been a fire
breakout we don't know
on what floor but it obviously people
have decided the thing to do is to go um
higher up on the building um i do let me
have a look if i've got any more
information for you i can tell you that
dozens of people about 350 360.
the the firefighters have been called as
well they are battling to uh try to put
out that fire at the world trade center
uh in hong kong it's uh in the causeway
bay area the shopping district many of
you will know that it's a 38-storey
building a lot of people that are in
that building have gone up onto the roof
it's both offices i'm told and also a
shopping center it was mid-afternoon
when it was uh reported so
a lot of people would have been around
either at their desk or shopping ahead
of christmas at least one person we're
told has been injured in the fire they
have
now been taken
taken to hospital firefighters are using
an extendable ladder 38 stories i bet
they are
to rescue several people who
have been trapped on the lower floors of
the building but as i said we're also
being told that people
have gone up onto the roof of well as
well other people said to be trapped in
restaurants as well in the mall
area that according to the south china
morning post newspaper
the fire has now been upgraded we're
told to a level three incident that
according to police
fires are graded on a scale of one to
five so you know it's pretty severe that
uh fire at the moment uh firefighters
have mobilized two breathing apparatus
teams and two water jets to help fight
the fire a lot of people have gone up
onto the roof uh it's 38 stories high
people are being uh rescued by the fire
service with extendable ladders uh lower
down people are trapped in restaurants
and also in their offices will get more
information and update you as soon as we
can meantime the husband of nazanin
zagari ratcliffe says he is hopeful she
could soon be freed richard ratcliffe
was speaking as a campaign song to
highlight his wife's continued captivity
in iran is released
[Music]
richard is with us hi um
richard did i recognize that little
person on the drums there
that was gabriella yeah so we went out
to the studio um last week uh had a
happy day in in liverpool um the band
were lovely and yes you had a happy time
playing all different instruments and
with varying levels of competence
but yeah very very much enjoyed her day
the iranians still want their 400
million quid back don't they um and you
um have been suggesting there might be a
way around that share it with us
yeah probably more guarded than your
intro there but yes it's clear the
iranians have been signaling the last
few weeks since the hunger strike that a
deal um is possible so the iranian
ambassador met with our mp to talk
through things and he's also been on the
airwaves and briefing the british media
um
different messages at different points
so mainly to say listen a deal is
possible come on the uk um points has
talked about the potential for settling
the debt through humanitarian aid and
through vaccines or other means
potential other times have been a bit
more clear about wanting their money
back in some form um and an iranian
ambassador was very clear that the deal
was very close a few months back um
under the former foreign secretary um so
you know we live in hope that it might
happen and guarded hope at this point is
as you see these christmas decorations
behind us make this the the sixth
christmas that we put apart um we may
need to keep battling for a while longer
of course
you went on hunger strike chatted to you
when you were outside the foreign office
did you get any traction with that
uh it's a really good question um i mean
certainly i think there was a much
greater understanding of our discontent
with the british government um you know
obviously it's the iranians who are
holding those being hostage but
the british have a part in this dude
they're the ones who aren't paying their
debt which prevent the whole thing um in
terms of what the hunger strike achieved
i think it achieved much greater
awareness i think it kept nazine out of
prison which was probably the trigger
for why we did it seems about put back
in prison um but in terms of moving the
government's position it not clear that
we have
um i've got a meeting with them tomorrow
to see where things are but we i pushed
pretty hard after the hunger strike have
a meeting with liz trust the new foreign
secretary um couldn't get one before
christmas
that must be very frustrating in the
meantime um how is nuzzan
i mean okay probably you know relieved
i'm not camping on the street um
starving myself um
probably as we get closer to another
landmark and christmas obviously is you
know christmas apart you know like it
has been for many of us last year um but
also
it's her birthday boxing day so it it
has this little double assembly like
another year and still stuck here and of
course in some ways
a year on like compared to last year we
were counting down at the end of her um
end of a sentence we thought we were
almost over at this point it's a lot
less certain quite what's going to
happen um we've got a new sentence
there's another british family where
they've had a second sentence being
talked about um so so she's pretty low
is the short answer um she was fine a
couple of weeks back it's been really
flat the last couple of days and that's
often the way in the build-up to these
landmarks um just you know wondering
where we'll turn around
we're always here um whenever you want
to come and talk to us either on the
telly or otherwise um love to the little
one um have a as good a christmas as you
can and uh whenever you need us to help
just pick up the phone thank you
um now the opening of a new train
service in laos isn't normally big news
but rail travelers have calculated the
launch of the new route now makes it
possible to travel from portugal
all the way to singapore by train
joining us now mark smith founder of the
train travel website seat 61.com hello
to you thanks for joining us mark this
sounds very
romantic
well it is although i prefer to start
from my local station here in the uk and
to go down to portugal and catch it
but uh it shows two things it's two
things have happened first of all
the
trans-siberian railway has been
highlighted as not just a curiosity in
russia but as a link between europe the
european rail system and the far east
and secondly this new railway in china
now links
the chinese rail network through laos
with the
with bangkok which of course is
connected by rail south to singapore
so the possibilities have just got uh
greater or at least they they will do
once we're out of the pandemic obviously
yeah what are some of the key spots
along the way you've highlighted some of
them there
well you travel through berlin and
warsaw and moscow there are two trains a
week from
moscow to beijing one takes the slightly
longer route through manchuria and the
other one cuts through mongolia and
crosses the gobi desert it's about 5 000
miles just from moscow to beijing it
takes six nights and it's not actually
that expensive if in
in relative terms about 500 pounds will
get you a bed in a sleeper from moscow
to beijing which is six nights
accommodation and almost 5 000 miles of
travel that's not
bad it's not the orient express though
is it
it isn't these are real trains these are
working trains trains for people who
want to get places and that's the good
thing about them because you meet people
you meet people you otherwise wouldn't
meet ordinary russians ordinary chinese
people mongolians
and talking and meeting with people like
that being connected to the landscapes
through which you pass that's one of the
great things about traveling by rail
rather than flying over everything at 35
000 feet do you think i mean where would
this uh land on your favorite rail
journeys of all time
well the trans-siberian has to be the
most epic train journey of them all and
i've traveled on it a couple of times
i've been from london to nagasaki via
vladivostok
and a ferry from there and i've been
from london to hong kong using one of
the moscow beijing trains and every time
it's different there's all sorts of
things to see and people to meet along
the way
um
everyone should do this it's a sort of
rite of passage i think it's one of the
great rail journeys of the world
i think i'm right in saying you can go
from wigan to vladivostok can't you by
train
you certainly can
yep through
london brussels berlin warsaw moscow uh
and uh direct train to vladivostok i
wouldn't go to vladivostok just for it's
a name to country with the best thing
about vladivostok was the ferry to uh
ferry to japan but there we go
i thought you're gonna say then i
wouldn't go to wiccan
no you would okay that's good
it's good to talk to you um it sounds so
romantic and so lovely we'll do it
together mark how does that sound thank
you very much indeed for joining us
great thanks a lot
i think he really really really likes
trains doesn't he i do too now we'll
discuss the introduction of new covered
passport rules coming up a suggestion
from the government this morning that
booster jabs could be made mandatory for
access to major public events in other
words you have to have three jabs in
order to get in to certain events
coming up the shadow chief secretary to
the treasury pat mcfadden uh will be
with us i bet he will also want to talk
about what happened last night a hundred
tory rebels voted against the government
and tomorrow it's a by-election more on
that to come in just a second
[Music]